- [Narrator] Russian
President Vladimir Putin said
that Moscow would
suspend its participation
in the last remaining major
nuclear arms control treaty
between the US and Russia,
the New START treaty.
(Vladimir speaking in Russian)
- [Reporter] Mr. President, any reaction
to Putin saying he's
pulling out of New START?
- Big mistake.
- [Narrator] Here's what
the New START treaty is
and what Russia's suspension means
for global nuclear arms control.
The New START, meaning New
Strategic Arms Reduction Treaty
was signed in Prague in 2010
by former President Barack Obama
and former Russian
President, Dmitry Medvedev.
It was an extension to START
I, which was signed in 1991.
This was a way to try to reset relations
between Russia and the
US after the Cold War.
The agreement was important
because these two countries
hold approximately 90%
of the world's nuclear weapons,
so the pact was created
to make sure this arsenal was controlled.
The treaty limits the number
of strategic nuclear
warheads that can be deployed
by either Russia or the US
to 1,550 and allows both sides
to inspect each other's
nuclear facilities.
Vladimir Putin said it was
time to suspend this deal
because Russia feels the US
has not abided by the agreement
by not allowing Russian inspectors
on US nuclear sites.
The US said it is Russia
that is blocking onsite inspections.
NATO Secretary General
urged Vladimir Putin
to reconsider the suspension.
- We have to remember that this is one
of the last major arms
control agreements we have.
- [Narrator] The Foreign
Ministry has said,
following Mr. Putin's announcement
that Russia would continue
to observe the limits on the number
of nuclear warheads it can
deploy under the treaty.
And he also said
that Russia would continue to
notify the US when it plans
to test launch intercontinental
ballistic missiles
and submarine launch ballistic missiles.
(Vladimir speaking in Russian)
- We'll be watching carefully
to see what Russia actually does.
We'll, of course, make
sure that in any of that,
we are postured appropriately
for the security
of our own country,
and that of our allies.
- [Narrator] This suspension means
that the US will lose
access to inspect some
of Russia's nuclear facilities.
And it's worrisome because
what Russia is planning,
whatever that is, it could
become more shrouded in secrecy.
But moreover, it calls into question
whether or not this agreement
to control nuclear weapons
can actually last now.
(nationalistic music)
China, for example, has indicated
that it wants to build
a large nuclear arsenal.
North Korea, as we know, has been testing
intercontinental ballistic
missiles and there's also concern
among Western officials that
Iran might actually be close
to making bomb grade nuclear fuel.
(nationalistic music)
The Journal spoke to the director
of the Pro-Kremlin Institute
for Political Studies who said
that if Washington doesn't
listen to Moscow now,
Putin may officially
withdraw from the treaty.
And if that happens, we
could expect a change
that would reduce the
US's nuclear security.
(dramatic music)